mindegy hogy miről de beszéljenek mert a
beszélgetés közben kibontakozódik a a a
az énye a másik személynek lehet látni
azt a azt a személyes oldalát amit amúgy
senki nem látna hogyha ha ha mind ilyen
virális videóként egy-egy percet
töltenek fel egy-egy olyan pillanatról
amikor éppen ideges vagy olyan
pillanatban amikor éppen nem tudom
cinikus vagy valakit kikacag vagy valami
akkor el lehet ezzel ferdíteni valakinek
a képét így a a a a közszférába de
hogyha három órán keresztül valakivel
beszélget akkor kialakul egy olyan kép
róla hogy persze egy-egy mondata kemény
más mondata nem annyira kemény egyegy
ilyen egyvele kialakul és ilyen az ember
valójában egyveleg vagyunk én sem vagyok
csak ilyen vagy csak olyan ahogy te sem
nagyon színesek vagyunk és és a podcast
az egy ilyen ilyen közeg